alright guys this is as I promised three
beep now the reason I'm highlighting it
is because there's a really great skill
for you to learn to develop as we have a
look at this question at last we're
learning to put his working on the board
because he was one who approached me
with this question and trying to work
out what is going on here because this
solution disagrees with the one in the
back of the book it actually says
correct me if I'm wrong well I think it
says this that right yep working out
what has gone wrong is a more important
skill believe it or not than getting it
right first time okay
real mathematicians are people who just
like get things effortlessly correct
actually real mathematicians spend 90%
of the time beating their head against
the wall because they're like it doesn't
make sense what have I done wrong okay
that's the clue that they know they're
on the right track because something is
difficult
I want to flex your muscles for looking
at working and trying to find out what
is it that has gone wrong because this
happens to all of us mrs. Leeson are
included so you have to be able to be
able to find where this is so let's walk
through it together okay do you keep in
mind you may not have approached the
question the way that will has there is
actually another way to do this that I
will show you I will show you later on
okay but you may have approached this
way let's try and dissect it this is the
original question integrate this guy
with respect to X okay now I want you to
follow with me the line of argument that
will has taken to get to what a solution
he's done this he's put two thirds at
the front that's fine because he's
multiplying by a constant you can
multiply or divide by any constant you
like why has he chosen 2/3 why that
number have a look at what he is done
particularly here what makes that line
better or easier to work with from
world's point of view it's easier to say
again Russell it's easier to find the
primitive so when we look at this guy
right I think we can all agree we know
how to find the primitive of this that's
no problem okay
some of you may well be at the point
where you can find the primitive this
and just just look at it and see what it
is but maybe you're not so world is
transformed it a little bit
do you recognize the form that this is
in this is in the form F dash on F right
so I'm okay with that
thumbs up he's multiplied by the right
thing you can see if I multiplied it
back in I would return to the original
line so he's done it correctly at least
with his you know trajectory in mine so
then he gets the next line
what's he done this two-thirds just
hangs out the front because it's a
constant that's fine mm-hmm he knows
that the integral of F dash on F is
equal to have a look at what he's done
log of what log of F right that's the
way reverse chain rule works for logs
so he's correctly done then that looks
good what about the half has he
integrated that successfully looks okay
right and he dutifully puts on the plus
C because this is an indefinite integral
so everything so far especially the way
that I've said it sounds fine right no
holes in logic no holes in the
arithmetic so why does the answer
disagree and this is a situation a few
of you Carter you like my answer is not
the same as the textbooks okay the root
reason why this is is because in math
there are many ways many parts to get to
the same thing and sometimes if you take
a different path you may end up with the
same answer but it may look different
and that is exactly the case here these
two lines are in fact saying exactly the
same thing they just look a little bit
different now you're not used to
thinking of X and three hex which is the
only difference between the two lines
I'll point out you're not used to
thinking of them as basically the same
thing but just looking different you
have to take a step back there's a lot
of context going around here okay and
the key is this guy over here you know
that plus C the one you've just been
used to writing out of habit because
mister we told you you or there was a
rule in text book or you had you know
it's and you're like I'd better put this
thing always somewhere I'll lose a mark
that plus C means something please
remind me again why do we put plus C
here
all right Oracle question why is a
simple one I'll put it negative in
simpler why is a simple integral like
this not equal to x squared
it's equal to X square plus C why say it
again but louder Russell this question
says what function must I differentiate
to end up back here and the answer is
there's a whole bunch of functions that
I could have differentiated that would
have given me 2x and the word Russell
used was there's a whole family of them
right there's a whole family based on
different values of seen please note
that C at this point could be anything
okay now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to put one more line of working on
two rooms just to make clear how it is
that these two things are the same okay
I'm right out of space on the right hand
side left hand side something right over
here use your minds and think with me
about your log laws okay
two-thirds outside of log now I can
write log three X in a different way
using a log law when there's a product
in here I can actually split this apart
into two logs kind of one of the two
logs going to be in this case log 3 plus
log X do you agree right and then what's
what else is hanging here minus 1/2 X
plus C is that okay now have a look
again what is the difference between
this line and the line in the textbook
and now it looks different doesn't it
this is the difference what is that well
it's it's 2/3 log 3 2/3 log 3 I don't
know what that is but whatever it is
it's a constant right do you see that so
what's the difference between this line
and the one that will has written which
I've just slightly adjusted here the
difference is it's a different constant
I don't know what that constant is
though so I don't really care it's just
slightly different if I wanted to I
could say plus C plus one it would just
be a different constant that's still the
same answer I wouldn't do that because
it's more complicated and that's the
same reason why the textbook has written
it like this rather than like this it's
not wrong
it's just irrelevant right if it's part
of the constant then I might as well
sign a sort of like combine it like boil
it in with this constant if I had for
instance you know plus five plus six
minus PI plus C C that whole long string
of things I could just replace them with
plus C because it's just a different
constant does that make sense and this
will not be the only time that you
encounter this what could we have done a
little bit differently over here and
like the first couple of lines that
would have taken us straight to this the
textbooks answer which is simpler slowly
rather than wills answer just took a
little more work to get there what could
I have done first
slightly differently who got there first
and got straight to the techs we set it
up anyone staying apart okay simplify
this line here but I'm going to simplify
a little bit differently right see this
three over three X it is f dash on F but
there's a simpler F dash on F that I
could use in the same spot I could
replace this with 1 over X it's still F
dash on F right it's basically the
simplest F dash on F that there is so
there's an overall principle here we've
talked about before you simplify if you
can before you differentiate you
simplify if you can before you integrate
does that make sense do you see how this
this is going to go straight there
no 3x involved you happy with that so if
your answer disagrees with the textbook
don't panic right away look at it
carefully logs are a little bit
different they play by slightly
different rules so that's why sometimes
they look more different than they
actually are